Podcast UFO mit Stefan und Flo, die lustige Internet-Comedy-Show. Mal geht's um Golf, dann wieder um Wein, darum schalten wir immer ein. Diese Folge hat Stefan zu viel Unsinn gekauft, deswegen wird seine Wohnung zwangsverpfändet. Podcast Ufo und jetzt alle mit Stefan und Flo, die lustige Internet-Comedy-Show mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will und allen möglichen Überraschungen. und mit dass manchmal auch Gäste dabei sind, was letzte Zeit aber ein bisschen vernachlässigt wird. Podcast anzubringen, als immer nur die Kommentare. Aber ja, wir nehmen das zur Kenntnis. Vielen, vielen Dank an Camilo für dieses fantastische Intro. Dankeschön. Das war ganz toll. Ja, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, dein Name ist Florian Tien Will. Ist immer noch so, das wird sich so schnell auch nicht ändern. Wird sich so schnell nicht ändern. Auch wenn wir tatsächlich letzte Woche in der Werbung gezogen haben, unseren Namen zu ändern. Nee, sich ändern, nur Buchstaben hinzuziehen oder wegnehmen. Ja, kann ich statt F einfach 14 F machen, Stefan? Geht das? Das weiß ich aber auch nicht, ob das geht. Warum gerade 14? Das ist doch der Louis CK-Gag. Ja, ja. 14 Fs, that's his name. Warum hat er den 14 genommen? Nee, weiß ich doch noch. 14 F. Ja. Weil es lustig klingt wahrscheinlich, 14. Ja, das ist ein sehr lustiger Name. Genau wie Douglas Adams ja auch 42 nur genommen hat als die Antwort auf alles, weil er fand, dass es lustig klingt. Moment, hast du gerade die Antwort auf die Antwort auf die Frage von allem gegeben? Ich habe die Antwort auf die Antwort auf die Frage von allem gegeben. Weil es lustig klingt, ist die Antwort. Weil es lustig klingt. Weil es auch einfach die Frage, ist es lustig? So, ja. Ist es lustig genug? Weil, er fand es, es klang lustig, 42, weil so eine boh, boh, boh, boh. Heißt, in allen anderen Sprachen macht es keinen Sinn, dann, nach der Logik, und Mathematiker haben sich umsonst versucht herauszufinden, was hinter der Bursche drin ist, meinen dann auch, ja klar, 42 ist durch sehr viel teilbar, sechs mal sieben ist zwei. Ja, aber 83 ist auch 42, 83 ist genau gleich. Es klingt aber lustig, 42, weil so die machen es den Mund lustig. 42, 42. Es ist manchmal so leicht, Sachen zu entzaubern. Ich habe letztens zum Beispiel auch der Weisse Hai, da sagt man ja wow, das ist so.
Das ist das Making-of geguckt und war total enttäuscht.
Das ist kein echter Hai. Und da sagt man ja, das ist ja brillant, weil die zeigen den Hai nie und das ist ja so eine geniale Idee, immer diese lauernde Gefahr. Ja, stellt sich raus, die konnten die nicht zeigen, weil keine Chance. Wie? Ja, nee, stellt sich raus, diese Hai-Attrappe hat nicht funktioniert.
Deswegen konnten die den so lange nicht verwenden beim Dreh, erst gegen Ende.
Das ist der ganze Grund, warum der Hai nicht drin ist und alle irgendwie... Ich bin immer... Ich liebe alles, was nach dem Sätzchen... Stellt sich raus kommt. Ja. Stellt sich raus? Ja, und ich bin direkt on the edge of my seat und höre mit mit grossen Augen und noch grösseren Ohren, höre ich dir zu. Einer der wenigen Begriffe, wofür ich das Deutsche mithalten kann, mit Turns out. Ja. Turns out ist schon sehr cool. Ja, stellt sich raus. Stellt sich raus. Turns out. Turns out. Giftig. Immer lustig. Stellt sich raus. Englisch. Ja, aber es stimmt schon. Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch leicht, Dinge zu verzaubern. Und zwar, es wird... Du verzauberst mich sehr häufig. Das ist nett. Und zwar, finde ich, kann man alles verzaubern mit einer Sonnenbrille. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe heute ein Kind gesehen mit einer Sonnenbrille und ich dachte mir, fuck, wie cool ist dieses Kind. Ich musste mich laut lachen. Ich will mit diesem Kind zusammen sein. Und Kinder sehen ja eigentlich scheiße aus, weil ich weiß nicht, wessen Ideen es war, alles, was mit Kindern zu tun hat, hässlich zu machen. Warum? Naja, so ein Fahrradhelm. Ach, du meinst Kleidung, große Köpfe, große Augen, süss. Ja, naja, aber es sieht auch ein bisschen doof aus. Also es sieht so ein bisschen unbeholfen aus. Klar, vom Anoraks, auch alles ist alles ein kleiner, lustiger aus erstmal. Ja, wackeln die so rum. Mittlerweile haben die ja auch Nike-Schüchen. Ja, das stimmt. Aber halt auch genauso wie unsere, nur in den Kleinen, das sieht einfach auch ein bisschen lustig aus. Ich glaube, das ist aber um Kinder auf den Boden zu holen. Also so, dass man sagt, die sollen scheiße aussehen, damit die nicht zu oberflächlich werden, damit die die inneren Merkmale kennenlernen. Weil irgendwann haben sie es dann verstanden, dass es egal ist, welche Kleidung man hat, weil man scheiße aussah. Deswegen wurden mir auch teilweise Kleidung gekauft, die nicht mehr Kleidung war, die wurde einfach so ein Kartoffelsack übergeschmissen oder so. Ja, das stimmt. Aber da fand ich auch eine gute Idee, weil als die Kartoffelhersteller gemerkt haben, dass die Kartoffelsäcke zu Kleidung werden, haben die so Muster auf ihre Kartoffelsäcke gemacht. Ja, das ist ausschliesslich für Kartoffeln gedacht. Ja, aber es ist ja auch eine gute Idee, wenn dann sozusagen das, was billig sein soll, dann auch wieder gut aussieht. Ja, genial. Wo wolltest du hinaus? Man hat Kindern jetzt angefangen, Sonnenbrillen aufzusetzen, um sie cooler zu machen. Ich musste einfach laut auflachen, als ich dieses kleine, unbeholfene Kind auf dem Dreirad gesehen habe, aber dadurch, dass es Sonnenbrillen auflacht wurde. Und es sah einfach sofort cool aus. Coole Kinder sind irgendwie, das bringt mich zum Lachen, coole Kinder sind einfach was, wo ich einfach irgendwie so ein Kind, das aus einem Auto aussteigt und dann nochmal so links und rechts guckt. Und ich denke mir, yes. Aber auch so mit runtergelassener Sonnenbrille auch so. Da mal kurz nach hinten oder so einer Frau nachschauen. Ja, genau, die die Sonnenbrille so runternimmt, um nochmal einen guten Blick zu kriegen. Aber nee, kein Pfeifen, das sind Gentlemen.
Schon sich satt sehen, aber dann nicht pfeifen, das sind die coolen Kids von heute. Und dann so einen Anzugknopf aufmachen. Ja, ja, oder aussteigen und dann so das Auto zumachen, so ohne hinzugucken. Beim Weggehen das Auto mit der Fernbedienung zumachen, das sind die coolen Kinder von heute. Bei mir, ich habe Nachbarn, das ist wirklich auch ein fantastischer Anblick immer, dann kommt immer zunächst der Vater raus mit einem Kinderwagen, dann kommt die Mutter raus mit einem Kinderwagen, die haben nämlich Zwillinge und dann kommen die beiden Zwillinge raus, die nicht im Kinderwagen sind, sondern für den Notfall haben die Kinderwagen mitgekommen, können aber schon ein bisschen gehen und die kommen auch beide mit jeweils im Kinderwagen raus, weil die damit spielen. Heißt, es sind vier Menschen mit Kinderwagen. Das sieht einfach aus wie eine Miniaturversion von dem Bild davor, wie so minimiert und nochmal gecopy-pasted hinten dran. Aber als Karawane ziehen die dann durch Köln. Aber alle Kinderwagen sind leer. Alle Kinderwagen, nee, das stimmt nicht. Ach so, die haben dann Puppen dabei. In den von den beiden sind Puppen drin. Naja, verstehe. Und jetzt meine Idee, können die nicht bitte auch noch Kinderwagen haben? Was ist mit dem Hund? Warum tut der nichts? Kein Hund. Aber heisst es dann, dass wenn die Kinder ohnmächtig werden und in die Kinderwagen müssen, dass dann die Eltern einen kleinen und einen grossen Kinderwagen schieben müssen? Die schieben den grossen vor sich her und ziehen den anderen so auch so lieblos hinter sich her, dass er so über den Asphalt noch geschliffen wird. Oh mein Gott, ey. Aber da dachte ich, das ist wirklich sehr lustig. Matruschka. Wie heisst denn immer diese Puppen, die man ein kleiner ... Babuschkauschka, oder? Das jedenfalls in echt. Ich finde auch, man sollte Flugzeugen Sonnenbrillen aufsetzen. Ja. Das ist der einzige, wie die noch ... Flugzeuge sehen fantastisch cool aus, jetzt schon. Naja, es sei denn, wenn die Schnauze so nach oben geht, dann sehen sie ein bisschen dümmlich aus. Dusselig. Dusselig aus, aber ansonsten sehen die schon cool aus. Schon cool aus, weil die auch so coole Augen.
Also entweder man macht denen noch so augenbraun,
so coole, spitze Augenbrauen,
dass die noch irgendwie so einen coolen Blick haben.
Es ist auch keine Airline, die uns auf die Idee gekommen ist,
jetzt krieg ich wieder links bestimmt,
aber es ist immer so cooler.
Ja, aber kann man denen auch mal irgendwie so ein cooles Toupe geben
oder so, dass man da einfach so ein bisschen
Kunstrasen, schwarzer Kunstrasen obendrauf...
Also Haare, die ja so im Wind wehen.
Und wenn die starten, sind wir einfach...
So ein Pferdeschwanz.
Es ist ein Wetter, der sich in den Wetter der Mund immer so Geräusche macht, also so Bewegungen macht. Ja, und wenn, genau, der sagt das dann auch Dinge, und wenn es dann, wenn es startet, dann ist dieses, was man von Fallschirmspringern kennt, wenn die Lippen so aus der Kontrolle geraten. So ist, wenn ein Flugzeug landet und startet, macht dieser LED-Screen dieses Scream. Oder wie bei so einem Huf, wo rechts die Zunge rausflattert. Das finde ich sehr lustig. Also ein LED-Screen, wo der Mund ist und dann immer so ein grosses Dicke machen. Kriegen die jetzt nicht irgendwie so krasse Subventionen die Fluggesellschaften und dann stellt sich raus, großer Skandal, wurde alles investiert. Obst für Schwachsinn, für Sonnenbrillen und Münder. Also eine Krisenkonferenz mit dem Verkehrsminister. Wo sind wir falsch abgebogen? Was ist passiert? Wir haben uns die Rechnung zuschicken lassen, da stand drauf riesige Sonnenbrille. Wir dachten, das ist halt irgendwas Technisches für einen Motor oder sowas. Aber nee, es war tatsächlich eine riesige Ray-Ban-Sonnenbrille. Die haben auch nochmal richtig verdient an der Stelle. Würde man sich da an Ray-Ban wenden, wenn man sagen würde, wir brauchen eine 30 Meter grosse Sonnenbrille? Sagen die, klar, wird es skalieren hoch oder ist es eine ganz andere Firma? Jetzt mal eine ganz kurze andere Frage. Wenn Ray-Ban ist ja auch ein Luxusguthersteller, also was für Sonnenbrille sind ja Luxusgüter, die werden ja gerade auch nicht gekauft, wahrscheinlich, tendenziell. Man nimmt ja gerade eher die billige Ray-Barry vom Mallorca als die gute Ray-Ban. Ist das dein Krisenprotokoll, dass du nur noch die zweitbeste Sonnenbrille kaufst? Nee, Rayberry ist die schlechteste Sonnenbrille.
Das ist mein Krisen.
Na gut, der Name könnt ihr dir sagen, das ist einfach eine nachgemachte Ray-Ban. Wer weiß, kann auch andersrum sein, kann auch andersrum sein. Naja, angenommen jetzt, also Luxusguthersteller, dem geht es nicht gut, wenn es Lufthansa, dem es auch nicht gut geht, bei Ray-Ban riesige Sonnenbrillen für Flugzeuge bestellen. Ray-Ban für die Materialkosten, also für das Material, auch bei jenen, der bestellt, der wahnsinnig in der Krise ist. Und die alle kostenlos fliegen dürfen mit der Lufthansa. Ich glaube, jetzt fangen wir an, Volkswirtschaft zu verstehen. Wir nähern uns, wir robben uns ran. Ich habe genug Wohlstand für alle gehört. Mittlerweile bin ich in meinen eigenen... Watch out, world, here I come with my own little theories. Wohlstand für Stefan, der neue Podcast. Wohlstand für mich. Stefan erklärt. Aber ihr könntet nur hören, wenn ihr auf patreon.com slash Wohlstand für Stefan geht. Damit Stefan sich wieder wertige Sonnenbrillen leisten kann, nicht damit diese Krise endlich zu Ende ist. Aber versteht ihr, was ich meine? Alle Firmen kaufen nur bei Firmen, die es auch schlecht geht. Und es wird so Geld im Kreis entsteht. Wie so ein Wirbelsturm. Der saugt dann den Mittelstand ein ein. Ja, und er ist dann weg. Vielleicht. Wo ist er hingekommen? Unter die Räder, ja. Oder in den, ja, unter die Flügel. In den Himmel oder unter die Erde oder unter die Räder. Unter die Flügel. Es gibt kaum negative Wort, Sprichwörter für Flugzeuge. Das hat die Fluglobby schon clever gemacht. Über den Wolken, im siebten Himmel, im Bordbistro, im Flyer-High-Mile-Club, sowas. Das ist alles positiv, wohingegen beim Auto, unter die Räder, am Gurt schmoren. Ja, machen wir das Radio lauter, das ist halt einfach alles. Ja, eigentlich das ist so die, weil Leute fragen sich auch, was machen eigentlich so Werbefirmen, PR-Firmen, die streuen Sprichwörter, damit man ganz unterbewusst Assoziationen hat zu gewissen Produkten, die nur positiv sind. Wer an eine Grube gräbt, war damals ein Hit, die groben Industrie ist eingebrochen, die komplette Bergbau-Minenindustrie. Wohingegen der Bäcker Grobe, der sagt, oh shit, das klingt so ähnlich. Ja, die Forstindustrie, wenn im Walten Baum umfällt und es hört niemand, die Forstindustrie war kurz vorm Zusammenbruch. Das waren ganz, ganz schrittschlimme Zeiten. Und erinnert man sich heute kaum. Kaum jemand schreit mehr in den Wald. Niemand, fast niemand mehr. Und wegschlafende Hunde. Hunde konnten, das haben Hunde auch, glaube ich, gestreut, weil, damit sie länger schlafen können. Ja, mein Gott, man sollte nicht schlafende Hunde weg. Warum eigentlich nicht? Ne, sag mal doch so. Oder? Du, jetzt habe ich noch mal eine Frage zu dem Sprichwort. Hallo, Entschuldigung. Hey, ihr habt doch alle gesagt, du sollst nicht schlafen, Hunde wecken. Ja, aber warum nicht, ist die Frage. Was ist denn so schlimm? Weil wir das, dann werden wir ganz wütend. Aber müde Hunde sind ja ungefährlicher als wache Hunde. Also sollte man Hunde doch eher oft aufwecken, wenn man Angst vor denen hat. Wie können die so lange schlafen eigentlich? Hunde? Ja, die schlafen auch ständig, den ganzen Tag. Tiere schlafen ständig. Wie steht das denn? Meine Tiere schlafen länger, als dass sie wach sind. Also das wird so albern. Die muss man irgendwie einschicken mal, das ist wie so ein Eiferung kaputt ist. Ja, da brauchen wir eine Riesenrückrufaktion irgendwie, das kann doch nicht so gedacht sein. Wie Pandas und Qualas. Das ist doch nicht mehr lebenswert. Wenn man Kuhu mit Kuhu ausspricht, warum dann nicht K-O, auch wie Q-Qualas? Ja, das ist kein lebenswertes Leben mehr, das kann nicht sein, wenn du nur so 20 Minuten wach bist. Ich habe ja damals, hatte ich eine Stauballergie, wurde ich so getestet und dann hieß es ja, was kann man machen? Und dann habe ich so ein Medikament bekommen gegen Allergie. Citrizin, wach müde. Und dann hieß es Nebeneffekt Müdigkeit. Zitrizin, Klassiker. Und dann bin ich in die Schule gegangen, kam nach der Schule nach Hause, war müde, dachte mir, ich lege mich kurz hin. Bin durchgeschlafen bis acht Uhr morgens den nächsten Tag, bin wieder in die Schule gegangen. Da dachte ich mir, das ist kein lebenswertes Leben. Ich habe zwar keine Allergie mehr, aber ich schlafe meine ganze Freizeit. Und dann dachte ich mir, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Ich habe auch immer Zetirizin genommen, habe aber durchgehalten. Ja? Ja. Nee, ich habe nicht durchgehalten. Aber jetzt die clevere Pharmaindustrie hat ja jetzt die Allergien, die ich nehme, heissen Reaktindu. Und da drin ist Zetirizin, macht aber leider müde. Und Koks. Und? Nein, Pseudoephytrin. Okay, das sagst du so, als wüsste ich, was das ist, aber ja. Naja, also kennst du vielleicht von Breaking Bad, weil am Anfang Jesse in der ersten Folgen auch immer das Pseudo braucht für das Crystal Meth. Pseudoephytrin ballert rein und macht dich wach und lässt sein Herz.
Es ist ein bisschen wie Koks.
Das ist, glaube ich, sogar auch ein Ampheter.
Ja, es macht dich zwar wach, aber dafür verstärkt es seine Allergie.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen der Nebeneffekt. Das heißt, du hast halt dann...
Am Ende kommt es ein Plus-Minus-Nober auf.
Es kürzt sich raus, aber du hast keine Nebeneffekt.
Ich nehme gerne Reaktion Duo, weil es mir danach einfach gut geht.
Keine Werbung. Danach bin ich gut drauf.
Und ich glaube, es ist nichts anderes als Meth.
Ist das schon das Werbesegment hier?
Ist nicht Werbung.
Es ist so halb Meth.
Es ist auch halb Werbung.
Wenn die mir jetzt Geld geben würden, und ich würde dir davon nichts sagen,
dann hätten wir ein verdammtes Problem.
Wie gross?
Riesengross.
Wie lange wärst du sauer auf mich?
Riesengross. Riesengross. So gross wie ein Mammtes Problem. Wie gross? Riesengross. Wie lange wirst du sauer auf mich? Riesengross. Riesengross. So gross wie ein Mammutbaum. Oh, jetzt habe ich dich. Wie gross sind denn Mammutbäume? 120 Meter. Weiss man nicht, ne? Dinge, die man nicht weiss. Sowas in der Richtung, 120 Meter? Ist das der grösste Baum der Welt? Ich glaube, es ist der grösste Baum, aber der wird natürlich auch behindert von all den anderen Bäumen. Wenn die ihn nicht mal loslassen würden, dann könnte er noch viel höher wachsen, glaube ich. Wenn die sich so in Klammern, so die wollen ja an dem hoch wachsen und die hängen sich an dem dran, an den Ästen und so. Das ist wie eine sehr tolle Metapher, die ich bis heute mal irgendwo einbauen will.
Also es ist keine Metapher,
es ist eine Geschichte aus der Natur.
Und ich halte das für eine tolle Metapher,
weiss aber nicht wofür.
Ja, wir können einen Metapher-Check machen.
Wir haben das Equipment da, es steht alles um.
Dann lass uns kurz in den Bip-Bip-Metapher-Check.
Schmeisse ich kurz die Maschine an.
Wie so diese Geigerzähler. Ja. Und zwar, gibt's, wenn du Krabben fängst? Mhm. Aber es muss schon ein schmissiges Sprichwort rauskommen. Das ist schon cool. Nee, das Sprichwort nicht, das ist eine Metapher. Ich weiß noch nicht, wofür. Ja, aber das muss schon jackig sein. Allergorie nicht, jetzt pass auf, stell dir mal vor, du fängst Krabben. Du fängst Krabben. Und die wollen natürlich alle aus diesem Eimer raus. Wenn einer raus will, werden die anderen aber neidisch und wollen auch raus, also halten die die Krabbe fest und ziehen die wieder rein. Ja, aber das ist doch die Hummer-Metapher. Ja, oder die Hummer-Metapher. Ja. Aber die wird regelmäßig verwendet. Ich habe es noch nie gehört. Wo wird die verwendet?
Also ich habe die zum Beispiel mal verwendet gehört, darüber, warum Frauen nicht oft in Führungspositionen ist, weil andere Frauen die dann den Erfolg nicht gönnen und die wieder runterziehen. Ich habe es noch nie gehört. Ob das stimmt, weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß es noch nicht, ob es Hummern sind, aber Lobster, glaube ich. Ja, ist ein Hummer Ich habe von einem Freund gehört, der Krabben gefangen hat an der Cote d'Azur und da hat er dann erzählt. Aber vielleicht ist es ein viel bekannteres Sinn, ohne es zu wissen. Es ist ein bekannter, deswegen Metapher-Check bestanden, Plagiat-Check nicht bestanden leider. Gut, dass wir beide Maschinen geholt haben, hat sich das doch gelohnt. Haben sich die einmal gelohnt. Wobei die Plagiat-Maschchine hat sich schon gelohnt. Oh ja, die müssen wir langsam wieder auswechseln. Da müssen wir wieder noch einen Kühler installieren. Müssen wir wieder nachladen. Auf jeden Fall. Okay, gut. Aber fällt uns nicht irgendeine Metapher ein, die es noch nicht gibt? Ich habe das Gefühl, wir brauchen eine blumigere Sprache. Irgendwie so den, der wird doch der Oh, ich habe heute aus Versehen ein Wort erfunden, und zwar habe ich geschrieben, ich bin noch nicht on loan, statt online, habe ich mich verschrieben, aber on loan ist ja die perfekte Metapher. On lonely. Ja, weil jeder ist doch, jeder kennt das doch, wenn man einsam abends im Netz herumsurft.
Man ist auf sich alleine gestellt, aber eigentlich ist man doch unter vielen, man ist unlon.
Unlonely, ja. Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Unlonely, I'm so unlonely, where are my friends, where are my friends, lonely. Und schon einfach im Original gelandet wieder. Nee, aber es hat auch den Rap-Test bestanden. Nicht schlecht. Gut, dass wir dieses ganze Equipment hier haben. Es lohnt sich wirklich. Leute denken immer, oh, Podcast, da braucht man ein iPhone 4 und kann dann anfangen aufzunehmen. Nein, man braucht viel, viel mehr. Das stimmt. Übrigens viel, vor allem braucht man euch, liebe Hörer. Und ich habe ein Dankeschön auszusprechen an jemanden. Ich finde leider die Nachricht nicht mehr, aber ich will mich bedanken, weil ein Hörer hat mir mein Wochenende versüsst. Mit dem Dinosaurier? Nein, mit einem Videotipp, einen Link, einen YouTube-Link von einem Broadway-Dirigenten, der im, also die Dirigenten-Cam, wie er das Orchester dirigiert von Hairspray, ein sehr erfolgreiches Musical, Mega-Musical. Und natürlich haben die ganzen Orchestermitglieder immer Monitore vor sich, damit sie sehen, wann die Einsätze sind, damit alle den Conductor sehen können. Und es gibt so eine sogenannte Pitcam auf den Dirigenten gerichtet, eine Schwarz-Weiss-Cam und sogar die Audiospur, die Originale, die er, die hören durch seine Mikrofon und durch die In-Ears, heißt, wir hören auch den Click-Track, der immer beginnt vor Songs, und er gibt die Einsätze, ich finde das fantastisch, ich hatte so viel Spaß daran. Kannst du mir das schicken? Ja, ich schickte das gern. Ich hatte da so viel Spaß daran. Ja, aber ist das das komplette Musical? Nein, nein, nein, es sind nur die Hits. Ach so. Es sind nur die Hits. Fantastisch, also da hatte ich so viel Spaß dran, weil es natürlich so ein super happy go lucky Musical ist mit You Can't Stop the Beat hinten raus, mega Hit, super fröhlich und er ist einfach, er macht das ja acht Mal die Woche, ist ja in einem Graben und dirigiert den Scheiss und irgendwann lachst du nicht mehr über die Witze, die auf Bühne passieren, obwohl es ein lustiges Musical ist. Räutest du mir mit den Augen.
Ja, und irgendwann hast du auch keinen Bock mehr auf diese Scheissmusik und er dirigiert das noch so locker runter und auch der Anfang ist gezeigt, wo er dann einfach nur ein bisschen Smalltalk mit so einem Musiker neben sich, man sieht nicht genau, was er für ein Instrument spielt, so um Smalltalk und irgendwie Haha, Gags macht und dann außerdem nichts, plötzlich One, Two, Three, four und dann beginnt einfach und im Publikum sieht man ganz viele grosse Augen von Leuten, für die das so die grösste Nacht des Monats ist und der Typ, er setzt sich einen Scheiss. Und für ihn so nebenbei, während er so ein lustiges Taschenbuch liest. Ja, und dann habe ich natürlich angefangen, da bin ich tief ins Rabbit Hole eingetaucht, weil dann habe ich auch andere Leute gefunden, andere Musiker und unter anderem einer, der im Abba, Mama Mia Musical, Schlagzeug spielt, wirklich fantastische Aufnahmen auch und dann nach der Overtüre hat er nichts mehr zu tun erstmal und hat sich ein Buch mitgebracht und fängt dann einfach an, dieses Buch zu lesen, was ich auch ein fantastisches Bild finde, wo man denkt, hört ihr doch wenigstens die Musik an, die andere Leute neben dir spielen. Nein, aber irgendwann ist ja auch, wenn du das wirklich zum zweitesten Mal diese Show spielst, ist dir vielleicht auch egal. Ja, das ist immer das Verrückte irgendwie. Und da gibt es ja auch zum Beispiel so Sinfonien, wo im letzten Satz dann noch ein Chor ist. Und da steht halt schon die ersten drei Sätze halt einfach da und guckt sich das halt an. Und das ist, glaube ich, was anderes, weil da kommt am Ende noch, da denkt man muss man auf Spannung sein, weil sein Einsatz noch kommt, aber auch so, wenn der früher kommt, dann stehen die einfach rum, wo ich mir auch denke, haben so Komponisten, hat dann so ein Beethoven überlegt, scheiße, die Fagotte machen schon seit 80 Takten gar nichts. Gib dir mal so ein B, halt so ein B, B, B, halt so was. Ich bin mir sicher, das wird auch in Betracht gezogen. Aber die hatten ja auch so Assistenten wahrscheinlich, die dann gesagt haben so, du, die Posaunen haben sich beschwert, die haben drei Töne in einer einstündigen Sinfonie. Die haben die jetzt kommen lassen, die meisten sind über drei Tage von Prag aus angereist. Ja, der eine ist an der Seuche gestorben, auf dem Weg hierher, der kommt hierher und um drei Töne zu spielen. Ja, was soll das für ein Scheiß? Ja, ba, ba, ba, was soll das sein? Ba ba ba ba. Ja? Ja. Aber wir beschweren sich, jetzt haben sie noch zwei Töne. Ludwig, das kannst du doch nicht machen, die kommen extra hierher mit einem Einton. Einton. Die können ja mit ihrem, mit ihrer Posaune so hin herschieben, ohne was zu machen. Ich glaube, es wird nicht ein Ding, und ich war auch schon in Sinfonien, wo dann nach Satz 1 Leute gegangen sind.
Aber nicht aus dem Publikum, sondern von den Musikern. Ganz vorsichtig zwischen den Stühlen so. Sorry, sorry, sorry, Entschuldigung. Beim Kontrabass, der immer so hin und her geht, müssen sie abwarten, wann der Bogen zur Seite ist, um dann durchzukommen. So ein Minigame ist ein Anschlusstermin. Sorry, ich muss weg. Sorry, ich muss weg. wahrscheinlich die am meisten Triangelisten Geschichte nicht wahr. Ja, für manchmal ist der beste Musiker den schlechtesten Einsatz, also die schlechteste Rolle. Nichts gegen Triangel jetzt, aber es ist ganz merkwürdig aus. Triangel, Triangel, Triangel, Triangel, Triangel. Du sagst Triangel. Trangel. Du sagst Trangel.
Also, du spielst die Trangel.
Natürlich, ich habe 14 Jahre, war ich im Konservatorium.
Können sie zumindest Triangel sagen.
Gut, Triangel.
So, dann die Psaunen.
So, Tropen, kommt ihr mal bitte ran.
Wir haben übrigens auch noch eine Mail bekommen von Luisa. Was hat sie? Luisa. Was war denn da los? Ich weiß noch nicht. Mensch. Jetzt ist es etwas sehr ernstes. Ich traue mich nicht, Gags zu machen, weil ich nicht weiss, worum es geht. Wenn es etwas ernstes ist. Florentin! Letzte Woche habe ich erzählt davon, dass ich hier rausgegangen bin, mich gefreut habe, meines Lebens und ein weisses Kaninchen gefunden habe. Ach so, ja. Ich habe nur das Kabel nervös gemacht. Ja, mir liegen sehr viel. Das habe ich gemacht, um uns nervös zu machen. Weil ich habe ganz viele XLR-Kabel auf dem Boden verteilt, dass es so aussieht, als ob unsere nicht angeschlossen sind. Es sieht aus wie so ein Rätsel, was man kennt aus dem Öl-Säft. Genau, so auf so einer Kellogs-Packung hinten drauf, wo man das dann einmal macht, einmal macht es trotzdem Mittag. Ich habe erzählt, dass ich weiße Kaninchen gefunden habe und Angst hatte, oh, kommen die zurück und du kanntest die auch, die weißen Kaninchen. Ja, weil ich daneben jetzt wohne. Stellt sich raus, Luisa kennt sie auch, denn Luisa erzählt, dass sie tatsächlich in Köln in derselben Strasse mal Kaninchen gesehen hat, allerdings weil sie auf dem Umzug war. Sie hat einen Umzug gemacht und dann hat sie diese Kaninchen gesehen und sie schreibt, nach vollbrachtem Umzug bot ich mich mit einem Auto an, etwas Bier zu holen. Es kam, wie es kommen musste. Ein weisses Kaninchen hopste vor mir auf die Strasse, ich versuchte auszuweichen, doch sah ich im Rückspiegel, wie es nicht mehr aufstand. Hab nicht mal gemerkt, wie ich es überfahren habe. Du hast letzte Woche gesagt, die kennen die Strasse, die gewöhnen sich an die Autos. Wann war das denn? Anscheinend, Luisa, keine Chance, einfach alle umgesäbelt, umgesäbelt, auf dem Weg, um nochmal schön Bier zu holen für ihre Saufgesellschaft da, wahrscheinlich selber stockbetrunken am Steuer, schön weisses Kaninchen auf dem Gewissen oder was. Das ist eine Anzeige, Luisa. Ja, das ist eine Anzeige. Fahrerflucht? Ja, Fahrerflucht, Sachbeschädigung, Bierhol, alkoholisiert am Steuer. Du wirst die gesamte Macht der deutschen Justiz zu spüren bekommen, nachdem wir mit der Petition durch sind, aber danach kümmern wir uns darum, dass Luisa so schnell nicht mehr an die frische Luft kommt.
Der Aufmeldürde des Kaninchens ist halt unantastbar.
Ja, ja, ich sag's doch.
Sag ich auch. Luisa, sag mal kurz bitte, wann das war.
Ach, jetzt sind wir still. Jetzt haben wir nichts zu erzählen, wenn es darum geht, irgendwelche...
Luisa, bleib still. Luisa, sie läuft, lauf! Haltet sie, sie steigt ins Auto, sie steigt ins Auto. Nein, sie hat schon wieder ein Karnischen. Es ist ein Paulaner, was hat sie in der Hand? Es ist ein Flaschenöffner, sie lacht. Luisa, stockbesoffen am Steuer. Also, das war nichts ... Also, mich nervt es, weil ich ... Also, es sind noch vier. Vielleicht waren es mal mehr. Mittlerweile sind noch vier. Ich habe nachgezählt persönlich. Ich weiss, wen die gehören. Und ich habe auch ein paar Mails bekommen, denn wir haben noch gesagt, die haben mich da draußen rumzuhoppeln, die gehören in den Käfig. Stell sich raus, nein, stellt sich raus, Kaninchen sind nämlich eigentlich wie Katzen, sehr tot, werden überfahren, wollen überfahren, werden den Drang danach, die sind am ehemlichen Revier, was sie gerne abhoppeln und wollen das auch pflegen und bereisen und die haben nicht, wie man sagt, als Mensch,
in kleinen Käfchen zu hocken, sondern auch die wollen gerne Freigang haben.
Und kann man deswegen genauso halten wie Katzen.
Die können auch mal raus und kommen dann auch wieder zurück,
weil die kennen sich in ihrer Umgebung gut aus, die kommen also auch wieder zurück.
Heißt, man hat die so zu halten wie Katzen im Prinzip.
Aber dass man das nicht weiß und dass wir es auch nicht wussten,
zeigt ja auch, dass die Känischenlobby da wieder ein bisschen zu leise war. Ja. Mal wieder. Oder die Käfiglobby zu laut, muss man auch mal. Kann man auch mal sehr kritisch. Oder die Werde zu laut? Die Käfiglobby war zu laut. Käfiglobby zu laut und Katzenlobby zu laut. Ja, ähm, Luisa war auch laut, hat einfach zack umgenietet. Keine Reue, lese ich aus dieser Mail. Null, eher Verlustigung auf eine Art. Null Reue, nicht sorry. Null Reue, aber die Fahne riecht man bis hierhin. Unangenehme Nummer, schreibt sie. Ja, das ist Mord, Luisa. Unangenehme Nummer, das hört der Staatsanwalt nicht gerne. Luisa, was sind Ihre, also sind Sie jetzt lebenslang, lebenslangehaft verurteilt, bei Ihnen liegt das letzte Wort. Ja, unangenehme Nummer, würde ich sagen. Bitte? Sayonara. Wie, Sayonara, unangenehme Nummer. Sie haben acht Menschen umgebracht. Wups, wupsi dupsi. Tja, Satz mit X war wohl nix. Satz mit X. Können Sie das aus dem Protokoll streichen? Nein. Nein, dafür ist es doch da, das Protokoll. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man das darf. Und wird das auch reingenommen? Hier wurde was gestrichen. Abgelehnt. Hier kam der Wunsch. Hier kam der Wunsch auf. 14 Mal in Folge. Können wir aus dem Protokoll streichen, dass ich gerade versucht habe, was aus dem Protokoll zu streichen? Abgelehnt. Können wir zumindest aus dem Protokoll streichen, dass ich überhaupt anwesend war? Abgelehnt. Steht alles im Protokoll. Mir wurde bei YouTube das beste Video der Welt angezeigt. Das mit den Bielen? Nein, das sind zwei Videos. Das erste erklärt sich schnell im Titel. Monkey on a Tiny Bicycle Steals Baby. Das war super. Das habe ich gesehen. Und es ist im Prinzip eigentlich alles drin, was der Titel verspricht. It's a monkey on a tiny bicycle. Tiny bicycle. Es kommt angefahren. In Thailand fahren die rum auf Fahrrädern, kleine Fahrräder, Mini-Fahrräder. Und es fährt an, es ist aus einer ganz schlechten Perspektive gefilmt, und es kommt angefahren, lässt das Fahrrad überkippen, nimmt das Baby und läuft mit dem Baby hinter sich hergezogen. Das Baby weiß nicht, was irgendwie geschieht. Das ist einfach nur über den Asphalt gezogen, vor diesem Affen, der auf diesem kleinen Fahrrad angekommen ist, mit so einer Klingel auch. Ich wusste, dass sich Zirkus irgendwann recht auf die Menschen.
Man kann Affen nicht beibringen, Fahrrad zu fahren.
Irgendwann brechen die aus und rächen sich.
Man kann auch Tiger nicht beibringen, durch brennende Ringe zu springen.
Irgendwann werfen sie mit brennenden Ringen auf dich.
Ja, und wir können nichts machen. Und die springen da durch.
Burning Rad Steals Baby.
Naja, Monkey in Tiny Plane Steals Grocery Bag. Das Wort Tiny auch so fantastisch. Aber es kommt auch so angefahren, wie so ein Klischee-Fahrrad. So ein Tring, Tring, Tring, Tring, Tring und Steal dann. Das war toll. Das andere Video, was noch besser war, war eine simulierte Gerichtsverhandlung von einem Jurakurs. Ein Jurakurs simuliert eine Gerichtsverhandlung. Die haben sich eine Richterin kommen lassen und zwei echte Anwälte. Und echte Verbrecher, einen echten Mörder. Aber alles andere haben sie gestaged und sich überlegt, es ist ein großer Spaß, kann man sie unbedingt angucken. Ob ich auf die Idee kam, mal wieder, was ich jetzt mal durchziehen möchte, wenn ich nächste Woche mal einen Tag frei habe, in der kommenden Woche, gucke ich mir eine Gerichtsverhandlung an. Ja, tu es. Man macht das viel zu selten. Viel zu selten. Denn Gerichtsverhandlungen, Urteile werden im Namen des Volkes il nomine publicule, urt vergeben, gesprochen. Das heißt, auch in deinem Namen. Auch in meinem Namen und ich bin meiner Bürgerpflicht noch nicht nachgekommen, mal zu gucken, was denn da immer so gesagt wird, was für Urteile verkündet werden, weiß ich nicht. Manche sind geheim, manche, vor allem so Familiengeschichten, sind oft nicht öffentlich unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit, aber die meisten Sachen kann man wirklich sehen. Und dann kann man, geht mal zum Amtsgericht, auf die Website des Amtsgerichts eures Vertrauens, meistens das bei euch in der Nähe. Holt euch Tickets. Holt euch Tickets und guckt mal, was da so geht. Weil, wobei jetzt gerade in Corona-Zeiten weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich, aber trotzdem, da muss ja stattfinden. Haltet auf jeden Fall die Regeln ein, keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls kann man dann draufgehen und dann sieht man wirklich dann so, es ist ein bisschen so Kinoprogrammmässig, sieht man, was da so passiert. Echt? Da steht dann immer nicht, also ich finde, da könnte ein bisschen mehr stehen. Da könnte für mich so eine Synopsis stehen, die man aus einer Fernsehzeitung kennt. Ja. So, Mann, 38er hat seine Frau verlassen, die ihn daraufhin umgebracht hat. Den Grund erratet ihr nie. Genau, ihr glaubt nicht, wer dann ins Spiel kam. Sein Vater, der vor acht Jahren schon mal verurteilt wurde. Sowas fände ich halt nicht so schlecht. Ist meistens nicht drin, sondern meistens ist nur Strafgericht, Zivilsache, Strafsache, was auch immer und ein Aktenzeichen dahinter, was einem auch nicht hilft.
Naja, man kann jedenfalls mal dahingehen und du hast jeden Tag mehrere tausend Verhandlungen, wo man einfach mal vorbeihopsen kann.
Also gibt es dann auch so Rituale, so muss man dann applaudieren, wenn der Richter reinkommt oder sich hinsetzen oder aufstehen.
Wichtig ist das Handy auf Anschlag laut aufzudrehen, dass falls ein Anruf kommt, Crazy Frog auf Lautstärke 100 dröhnen. Das ist schon wichtig. Ja. Vor allem verzerrt. Und kann man da gehen während der Verhandlung, oder ist es dann so wie so eine Achterbahn, wo man wirklich erst aussteigen darf, wenn es durch ist? Du darfst erst aussteigen, wenn es ... Es ist vor allem eine Achterbahnfahrt der Gefühle, glaube ich, denn es kommt bis auf die Strafsache an.
Aber man kann ja schon ein bisschen beeinflussen, oder?
Weil wenn er dann sagt so, aber sie ist fremdgegangen, und dann denkt der Richter auch, oh scheiße, stimmt.
Man kann dann schon so Drama-Punkte machen.
Ja, auch mit den Blicken den Richter so lenken, mit so einem, das klang gerade bei der Rückfrage aber noch anders, oder?
So blicken so, oder auch ganz vehement in den Kopf schütteln, wenn man glaubt, die lügt. Nee, ich glaubte ja kein Wort. Ich glaubte ja keine Silbe. Oder lachen, wenn man Dinge nicht glaubt. Nee, ich bin, nee, zu der Zeit war ich noch nicht da. Ich bin auch niemand, ich bin auch niemand, der so reagieren würde. Genau. Der war gut. Also Chips essen dabei. Ich war auch mal so drauf, so belustigt, als wir mit der Uni mal in einer Gerichtsverhandlung waren, da hatten wir Medienrechte oder sowas, und dann war man trotzdem mal in einer Gerichtsverhandlung. Und dann war ich auch so, ach geil, jetzt mal schön wegsnacken, hier so eine schöne, ist halt wie Barbara Saalesch live im Prinzip. Guckt man auch im Fernsehen, kann man das auch gucken, war ja auch ein großer Hit, hab ich nie geguckt, aber war auch immer sehr erfolgreich. Und dann bin ich da so hin, mit gefühlter Popcornhut in der Hand und dann war das leider aber ein fahrlässige Tötungs. Bei Medienrecht? Nee, ja, wir waren da halt, um uns in Griechwanderung anzugucken. Ich dachte, was ist das schlimmste Verbrechen, dass es Medienrecht gibt? Eine krasse Urheberrechtsreizeit. Ihre Coinflakesfigur sieht sehr ähnlich aus wie Duffy Duck. Nein? Na klar, die hat denselben Schnabel, dieselbe Hose. Ja, ist eine andere Farbe. Ja, ist doch dieselbe Hose, es sieht auch jeder. Und das Publikum weint.
Viele Tränen, Tränenkollern im Publikum.
Das ist ein ganz anderer Gesichtsausdruck.
Oh mein Gott!
Nur weil es eine Ente ist, jetzt ist plötzlich jede Ente Daffy Duck, oder was?
Die Mutter von dem Verteidigenden springt auf im Publikum und sagt,
nein, nein, das ist wirklich keine Ente. Natürlich, das eine Ente, sie sind in einem Schnabel. Und dann war es tatsächlich ein fahrlässiger Tötungsdelikt. Ja, und du mit deinem Jersey-Shirt und dem grossen Hut und dem Einserfinger. Das ist im Namen des Volkes, Pulli. Im Namen des Volkes, so ein grosser Hammer, so ein Gummihammer, so ein Richt. Oberkörperfrei und so ein Paragrafenzeichen auf dem Bauch gemalt, aber uuuhu, recht und mit einem grossen Hammer aus dem Guggen, der auch so Geräusche macht, so die, ne, ne, wenn man ihn schlägt, so ein grosser Hammer und der schraubt, so im Namen des Volkes. Ich bin der grösste Fan von rechts. Ich bin ein Rechtsstaatsfreund. Schal. Bargraf 135, wuhu, wuhu, den liebe ich. Und dann war ich da ganz bedrüppelt in meinem Rechtsstaatsoutfit und dann dann war das nicht so lustig, tatsächlich.
Da war auch die Familie dann da von dem Opfer. Aber solche Verhandlungen dauern noch viel länger als einen Tag, oder?
Ist das dann so Tag eins von acht?
Ja, genau. Tag eins von 573.
Das ist schon schlimm.
Ja.
Jupp.
Und für ein kleines weisses Kaninchen gab es keine Verhandlung, weil die Täterin nicht aufzufinden war. Wo kein Kläger, da kein Täter. Ja. Aber wir sind ja jetzt sowas die Kläger, ne? Mhm. Luisa? Wir nehmen das in die eigene Hand, wir brauchen auch keine Polizei, wir sind Renegades, wir nehmen das in die eigene Faust. Wir sind keine Snitches, wir sind unterwegs mit unserem eigenen Gesetz. Wir schmeißen uns aufs Puffer-Mobil und dann wird gelüncht. Aufs Justice-Mobil, dann gucken wir mal, wer hier Leute überfährt, wer hier ein schönes Bier sich gönnt. Nicht du! Warum bist du zum Kiosk gefahren vor allem? Hättest du ein Leben schenken können. Ja, das stimmt schon. Man muss nicht mehr Bier holen fahren. Ich gehe noch mal Bier holen. Man geht Bier holen. Wenn aber. Oder man lässt es sich kaum mit Flaschenpost. Das ist doch eigentlich, hast du mal Flaschenpost in Anspruch genommen? Nein, warum nicht? Es wirkt wie etwas, was für dich gemacht sein könnte.
Nee, ich bin tatsächlich jemand, ich gehe ja gern oft klein einkaufen, kaufe zwei, drei Sachen, die ich für den Tag brauche.
Aber dafür jeden Tag viermal.
Ja, dafür jeden Tag viermal. Ich bin so, oh, jetzt will ich eine kleine Tüte Ringlies oder so und dann hole ich mir eine Tüte Ringlies und dann habe ich die.
Und dann mal gucken, was der Nachkauf noch bringt.
Nie einen Vorrat oder so, das ist nicht meins. Ich habe keinen Vorrat, weil sonst will ich alles auch sofort aufessen. Lebst du eigentlich in der ständigen Angst, deine Wohnung aufgeben zu müssen? Weil genau so richtest du dich ein und so ernährst du dich auch. Ja, ich versuche tatsächlich schnell einen Fluchtweg. Also ich versuche auch, dass ich alles, mein gesamtes Inventar in zwei grosse Sporttaschen ... Du lebst ein bisschen dein Leben wie so ein Kinderschänder, ehrlich gesagt.
Falls es outfällt,
kannst du sofort weg ...
Ja, ich sag mal so, also mein Fluchtweg ist
zu gut geplant.
Ich habe da zwei grosse Ikea-Taschen stehen.
Aber die Strafe ist noch nicht begangen, aber die Fluchtweg
ist nicht glatt. Der Motor läuft schon
vom Fluchtwagen, so gefühlt.
Der Motor läuft schon, ich habe in Mexiko
ein kleines Apartment gemietet, einfach so, mal gucken, was passiert. Da ist schon mal die Klimaanlage an. Genau, die Klimaanlage ist schon mal an, ich habe so einen kleinen Schnurrbart, so ein kleines Mexiko-Vokabelheft, alles drin, Buenas Notches, und dann einfach mal schauen, was passiert, einfach weil ich will schnell auf dem Fuss sein. Ich habe tatsächlich Angst, weil ich denke mir so, wenn ich immer so höre, jemand hat jemanden umgefahren und Fahrerflucht begangen, höre ich tief in mich hinein und da sagt eine kleine fiese Stimme, ja, das würdest du auch machen. Ich habe, ohne zu spoilern, Detomy ist in die zweite Staffel gegangen. Ohne zu spoilern, der Typ, der durch die Fahrerflucht begann, war ich. Detomy ist in die zweite Staffel gegangen, da ging es in der ersten Staffel auch um Autounfall und Fahrerflucht und sowas in der Richtung. Und da dachte ich mir auch jedes Mal, allein in dem Panikmoment, so du fährst durch die Gegend, fährst jemanden um, irgendwie nachts, niemand hat es gesehen und du denkst dir, also da dann zu sagen, da dann keine Fahrerflucht zu begehen ist schon, finde ich beeindruckend. Aber ist es da nicht gerade einfach, das zu gestehen, weil du ja nicht so viel kannst? Ja, aber in dem Moment, Stefan, so. Klar, man kann es immer abstrahieren, von seinem hohen Ross herunter irgendwie auf seinem Paragrafenstapel dann zu sagen, ja, aber in dem Moment. Ich bin meinem hohen Ross. Ja, aber kann man es nicht gerade dann am besten. Ja, ich glaube eh, ich glaube eh, in Notsituationen sind wir alle schlecht. Wer hat hier ein Pferd ins Gerichtssaal gelassen? Wo ist Ross? Ich will von meinem hohen Ross herunterrufen. Ross. Schönes Wort, Ross. Ross, schönes Ross. Da merkt man noch so, dass die mal wichtig waren in der Gesellschaft. Pferde waren mal wichtig. Pferd. Jetzt ist Pferd. Pferd, Ross. Pferd und Pony. Das ist nicht mehr so wichtig. So, Frösche waren nie wichtig, weil du hast nur ein Wort für einen Frosch. Nie in der Geschichte der Menschheit war ein Frosch wirklich essentiell. So, wir brauchen jetzt dringend mehr Frösche. Nie! Aber Pferde waren wichtig, Schweine, Kühe
so, aber so
also die Wortwolke
rund um Frosch ist minimal.
Bei Pferd hast du Galopp,
Sprint, Trab, Ross,
ja, Pony, Zottel,
Pferdeschwanz, ja, da hast du
das ganze Vokabel hervor. Stallion, um an einer
Sprache zu bemühen. Ja, aber
Frosch, hast du Frosch, Frog, Frogo und das war's.
Stimmt, nur Frosch, Kröte, Kröterich und Fröschchen. Kröterlinchen, gut, klar, da gibt es das natürlich im Kinderbuchbereich. Das stimmt schon, je mehr Wörter es gibt für etwas, desto wichtiger. Hättest du, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, pass auf, hier sind 12.000 Euro und du schreibst mir mal so ein saftiges Kinderbuch. Wärst du da dabei, hättest du da Spaß dran? Kinderbüchlein? Ja. Naja, ich denke da so voll an grosse Buchstaben. Ja. Ich denke so voll an Zeilenabstand 100. Ich denke an sehr viele Bilder. Satzzeichen brauchst du nicht. Ich denke an viele Bilder, wo ich sagen kann, ja, dann müsste ja nochmal der Illustrator das machen. Das müsste ja nochmal, das müsste ja der Illustrator sich, ne? Ich denke an viele Ausreden. Ich denke an wenige Sätze, die ich schreiben muss. Das ist ein guter Ansatz. Und dann denke ich an die 12.000 Euro, die du angeboten hast. Und dann wie viel Steuer haben. Und dann denke ich mir, wie viel abgeht. Dann denke ich mir, 40 Prozent kann man direkt abziehen.
Ich hatte eine Idee für ein Kinderbuch, und zwar ein Kinderbuch, das man Kindern vorliest, wenn sie krank sind. Das ist so eine Art Kinderbuch, aber gleichzeitig Medizin. Das Kind geht schlecht, das Kind ist krank, aber dann sagt das Kind, jetzt kannst du mir dieses Buch vorlesen. Und das Buch ist Hysterich und Schnieferinchen. Das sind zwei, Hysterich und Schnieferinchen sind zwei Freunde und die besuchen immer Kinder und machen die krank. Also husten und schniefen. Aber die sind halt niedlich und süss und erleben Abenteuer und so und die werden dann immer weggebracht, weil das Kind dann gesund wird und so und dann ziehen die so durch die Geburt. Dinge, die eigentlich schlecht sind, werden süss und nett gemacht. Gibt es auch Hüsterisch, ich denke schon an Merch, ich denke schon an Hustensaft, ich denke schon an absetzbare Umsätze, ich denke schon direkt an Hüsterisch und Schnieferinchen, Figürchen, so Stofffigürchen. Kleine Figürchen, dann was braucht man, wenn man krank ist, so einen Lappen, den man, au, heiss oder kalt, weiß ich gar nicht, auf die Stirn legen kann. Fieberthermometer? Das ist geil. Was ist denn mit Fieberow? Hüsterich, genau, Fieberow. Fieberow, Fieberow, Fieberow, Fieberow, Fieberow hat man auch noch dabei. Das ist der Ärztsein. Ho, hallo, ich bin Fieberow. Mit Schnieferinchen. Ho, Schnieferinchen. Hüsterich, Hüsterich. Ich bin Fibero. Mit Schnieferinchen. Oh, Schnieferinchen. Und Hüsterich. Hüsterich. Ich bin Fibero. Ich bin Hüsterich. Ciao, Fibero. Fibero ist der Erzfeind, der Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen immer besiegen. Fibero ist eine Form der Abwehrkräfte. Genau, die Abwehrkräfte und dann so eine Bettdecke oder so. Ja, halt alles, was man braucht. Und dann glaube ich, wenn das Kind dann krank ist, freut sich das Kind, weil es wieder eine Geschichte von Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen vorgelesen bekommt. Und dann geht es dem Kind gleich besser.
Oder will das Kind dann das Hysterische immer wieder besuchen und dann legt der Herr Niklas dann auch noch mal den Tisch ab in der Kuschel-Ecke.
Das ist ja so das Ding wie mit der Zahnfee, dem Kind fallen die Zähne aus. What the fuck, mein Körper geht kaputt. Die Eltern sagen, nein, nein, das ist gut, wir geben dir ja noch Süßigkeiten dafür oder Geld. Wenn du die Zahnfee, geniale Idee, schlechte Dinge kombinieren. Deswegen, wenn das Kind krank ist, zack, kannst du da direkt. Und Merge ist eine geile Idee, bin ich direkt dabei. Waschlappen, Fieberthermometer, Hustensaft, ja, diese Wickel, keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich da nicht so aus. Pfefferminztee, Hühnersuppe oder so, kannst du die ganze Linie machen. Weil das kannst du dann alles branden und den Kindern macht es Spaß. Die sind dann viel lieber krank. Hüsterich ein Schifrinchen. Ja. Is it a worst bird production? Could be a worst bird production. Ich weiß nicht, wie schwer es ist. Aber muss man da nicht so... Ich glaube, um auf den Medizinmarkt zu kommen, ist glaube ich, da haben wir uns gerade... Naja, du musst ja eigentlich nur... Nachdem wir mit dem WC-Entend den Hygienemarkt nicht mal ansatzweise in die Bedrohle bringen konnten.
Naja, du musst ja nur auf den Kinderbuchmarkt und es gibt ja wahrscheinlich eh schon mit Hustensaft oder so Verträge, so Lucky Luke Hustensaft oder so. Ja, wick. Pflaster, na Pflaster passt nicht oder so. Pflaster passt gar nicht. Aber naja, du musst ja erstmal den Kinderbuchmarkt erobern und dann kommst du weit, dann von da aus geht es dann weiter. Seid ihr Illustrator, Illustratorin, dann schreibt uns doch bitte, vor allem unter der Voraussetzung, dass ihr Bock habt, ein Kinderbuch mit uns zu machen. Schickt uns in so einer Vorder- und Profilansicht Hysterich und Schnieferinchen bei Nacht, bei Vollmond und bei Sonne. Ja, und vielleicht so in Animeform,, falls der asiatische Markt auch noch offen ist. Einmal macht die Augen ein bisschen größer, eigentlich kontraintuitiv, dass Animes grössere Augen haben, vielleicht Überkompensation, weiß ich nicht. Aber die sind halt so Tränen unterlaufen, weil die sind halt beide richtig fucking krank. Die sind richtig krank? Also diese Schnieferinchen, riesige Nase, die läuft. Grosser Schal um. Grossen Schal. Die Hüsterich hat eine hohe, grosse Mütze auf. Und ganz blass sind beide, ganz blass. Ganz blass, Augenringe. Und das sind so ein bisschen eigentlich die vier Reiter der Apokalypse, die so richtig die Menschheit in Probleme werfen. Hat Schnieferinchen auch so einen großen Rotz-Tropfen,
der so aus ihrer Nase kommt.
Und der hat noch mal ein eigenes Gesicht.
Das ist Rotzi,
der ist dann so der Sidekick. Dem geht's gut,
weil der freut sich ja, wenn Leute
da bin ich wieder.
Und dann wird er immer so reingezogen.
Und die Kinder.
Und dann wird er immer so rein,
zieht ihn dann immer so rein und dann ist er weg. Wenn er nervt. Wenn er nervt, wenn er dann sagt er irgendwas unsittliches. Und er wird da immer wieder reingezogen von Schnieferinchen, was jetzt nicht die beste Botschaft der Welt ist, man soll das nicht reinziehen. Eben. Aber muss man, also ist das nicht so? Eben, daran stirbt auch Schnieferinchen auf Dauer. Moment, aber ganz kurz, wie geht das denn aus, wenn am Ende des Tages die Krankheit besiegt ist und die beiden weggeschickt werden? Werden die weggeschickt, sind diese Metapher oder sterben die? Die Geschichte fängt immer gleich an. Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen liegen auf der Lauer und lauerndem Kind auf. Fröhliches Kind spielt im Kinderspielplatz oder im Schwimmbad oder sowas. Immer beide auch. Beide zusammen, ja. Spielt, hat eine schöne Zeit. Und Magen und Darm, die beiden Brüder. Das ist der Spin-off. Ja, aber die könnten ja so, oh, wer kriegt das Kind zuerst, sozusagen. Und dann fallen die das Kind an und zerren es halt in so eine Gasse und machen es krank. Und dann ist das Kind zerren das Kind in eine Gasse? Oh mein Gott! Ist das Kind krank und dann... Wie machen krank und dann wie machen sie es krank die fliegen in die Körperöffnung rein machen das Kind krank nein Schnieferinchen geht durch die Nase Hüsterich durch den Mund steckt sich da in den Mund rein und dann ist es halt so ein Kampf oh die Mandeln versuchen sich zu verteidigen aber keine Chance, Hysterich schlägt die Mandeln ins Gesicht.
Auch weil du als Autor des Buches nicht genau weißt, wie Mandeln funktionieren.
Keine Ahnung, Nasenschleimhaut.
Also sehr vage geschrieben alles.
Extrem vage, also für Kinder so ein bisschen runter, medizinisch-wissenschaftlich ein bisschen runtergebrochen.
Und dann sitzen die da drin und dann machen die das Kindheit krank und dann kommen die Abwehrkräfte und so und dann kommt Fibro, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, Ja, wie gesagt, da habe ich dann auch eine schillernde Persönlichkeit, Fibro.
Eigentlich die coolste Figur im ganzen... wenn man die Seite aufklappt mit Fibero. Ja, wie gesagt, da habe ich dann Autoren. Auch eine schillernde Persönlichkeit, Fibero.
Eigentlich die coolste Figur im ganzen Buch.
Im Prinzip.
Mark und Damen, beiden Zwillinge, beiden Brüder.
12.000 Euro, du schreibst mit 12 Bände.
Wie diese Pixie-Bücher.
Wie ganz kleine, vor allem du brauchst mehr, das Kind muss sehen,
oh da sind noch ein paar.
Die nicht umsonst waren, by the way, ne? Doch. Nein, Pixie-Bücher sind nicht umsonst, das denken immer alle. Pixie-Bücher, die draußen immer vor Bücher-Handlung stehen, als wären sie umsonst, sind nicht umsonst. Da sind schon hunderte Eltern ins Gefängnis gewandert, weil sie dachten, die nehmen das so mit. Wenn man mir jetzt noch sagt, dass diese Bonbons beim Arzt nicht umsonst waren, sind nicht kostenlos.
Ja, dann bin ich jetzt bereit für den Galgen. Aber er zahlt die Versicherung meistens. Bei Pixie-Büchern vielleicht auch. Das stimmt, aber vor allem das ist wichtig, das Kind muss sehen, dass da noch ein paar im Schrank sind, die es noch nicht kennt. Weil dann immer, wenn es krank ist, jetzt weiß ich, wie es weitergeht. Aber die sind leer, die habe ich noch nicht mehr. Wir nehmen einfach nur, wir malen,
lassen die Illustrator,
diese indischen Illustratoren, die wir
dafür bezahlen, die lassen wir noch fünfzig
andere Cover malen. Aber es stimmt
schon, eigentlich bräuchte man auch eine Fieberfigur.
Also nicht Fieberroh als
Fieberthermometer,
sondern eigentlich noch Fieber,
Fieber, einfach noch so eine
coole Figur, der Skateboard ankommt. Ein 80s Disco-Stu. Fieber, Fieber, einfach noch so eine coole Figur, der Skateboard ankommt. Ein 80s Disco-Stu. Fieber, Fieber, der so ankommt, vielleicht auf so einem fliegenden Skateboard oder so. Hey, ich bin Fieber. Und der hat so Flammen, zieht er hinter sich her, war alles heiß. Ich weiß nicht mehr, worauf es so raus wird. Naja, weil wenn du krank bist, hast du ja Husten, Schnupfen, Fieber. So, und Husterinchen, Schnieferinchen kümmern sich um Hust und Schnupfen. Daher kam eigentlich Fieberro. Ich dachte Fibero ist das Fiber-Termometer. Nee. Ach so, ja dann Fibero, okay, verstehe. Ich dachte, Fibero ist Fiber. Okay, dann ist Fiber eher dann so das Fiber-Termometer. Aber ist Fiber nicht ein Abwehrkrank, ist Fiber nicht gut, ist Fiber nicht vom Körper aus, damit die... Ja, ich stelle doch nur Fragen, du hast einfach keine Ahnung. Immer wenn du keine Ahnung hast, sagst du, wir müssen es reduzieren für die Kinder. Nein, nein, nein, diese Fragen müssen die verzweifelten Eltern beantworten, wenn das Kind fragt, ja, aber wie funktioniert das? Dafür sind Eltern da, die müssen sich da durchwursten, die müssen sich da irgendwie durchweseln. Aber gibt es nicht irgendwie so ein Gremium, wo man durch muss, um ein Kinderbuch zu verkaufen? Weil du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, ich habe jetzt hier meinen Kampf abgeschieden. Was ist das für ein Gremes. Naja, halt irgendwie so ein Pädagogen, Elternbeirat, Janosch, Michael Ende, ja, kann schon sein und Brösel und El Kessner sitzen dann da und Brösel und sagen alle, ob man das machen kann oder nicht oder was. Wie bei The Voice of Germany sitzen die alle mit dem Rücken zu dir und dann musst du dann, dahin kommt auch eine Rockshow, dann musst du dahin gehen und musst dann das Kinderbuch vorlesen und dann drehen die sich um oder nicht. Ja, aber ich glaube, also es muss ja irgendjemand kontrollieren, was in Kinderbüchern steht und was nicht. Also du kannst ja nicht irgendwie so eine Hardcore, ja, aber wer macht das? Haben die Verläge sich dazu bereit erklärt, das zu machen? Aber du kannst doch nicht irgendein Buch schreiben. Es muss doch jemand lesen. Wir können jetzt auch nicht einfach ein Buch schreiben und es rausbringen. Ja, aber normalerweise ist es egal, was du in dein Buch reinschreibst. Nee, mit Sicherheit nicht. Naja, aber es gibt bestimmt irgendeine spezielle Instanz, durch die Kinderbücher durchmüssen, durch die normale Bücher nicht durchmüssen. Gibt's bestimmt. Und da sitzt dann Michael Ende da und Rolf Zukowski und die sagen, nein, nee, ich finde das nicht gut, dass Fibero so eine positive Figur ist, weil Fiber ist was Schlechtes. Ja, wir finden es nicht gut, dass Fibero nackt, komplett nackt ist. Das gefällt uns nicht. Ja. Und dann rollt Rolf Zukowski seine Gitarre hervor und hat dann dazu nie geschrieben. Damals in den 70ern, da waren wir alle nach. Ich dachte, ich würde die Kritik euch so mitteilen, aber ich dachte, ich schreibe auf einen Song. Fibero, Fibero, Fibero, nanananana. Ja, weiß ich nicht, aber ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so leicht, da durchzukommen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube auch nicht. Also lassen wir es, oder? Lassen wir es, Projekt beerdigt. Ehrlich gesagt nicht. Wenn du bereit bist, dann eine schöne Geschichte zu schreiben. Aber das ist natürlich die Frage. Ja, nee, aber... Wir brauchen halt auch Kinder, die das dann bewerten, also ob das gut ist oder nicht. Wir können ja mal... Thais, das ist der ehesten Kind von uns. Was macht Thais jetzt eigentlich? Hat Thais das Abi gemacht? Nein. Jo, die war doch 16, oder? Die war vor zwei Jahren 16. Du, ich weiß es gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Sie ist so ein bisschen aus dem Vogelhäuschen geflogen. Wir haben sie so ein bisschen nicht verstossen. Wo ist Thais? Ich hoffe, ihr geht's gut. Thais? Sag mal, ob sie es dir guckt. Schreib mal kurz. Du, die ist doch jetzt komplett zu gemischt,chtes Hack übergewechselt. Du glaubst nicht, das ist irgendwie das uncoole Podcast-UFO, wo sie mal ihr Praktikum gemacht hat. Das hört ihr doch nicht mehr. Nee, stimmt. Wir sind so eine Praktikumstelle. Es ist sie bestimmt irgendwo wirklich in so einem krassen Sex-Podcast oder sowas. Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Wir sind so wie so die Lokal-Nachlasten, wo man dann so Praktikum macht. Genau, wo man sich nachher schämt im Lebenslauf so. Ja, später in zehn Jahren, bis ich Praktikum gemacht habe, dein Podcast-UFO. Oh nein! Ja. Oh, wie langweilig. Ja, die haben mich schon so machen lassen und so und es war irgendwie ganz, ganz, wenn die war, dass das okay. Das ist nicht die, die dann irgendwie so ein Kinderbuch ausgebracht haben, das mega ins Kanteil gemacht hat. Ja, und der eine hat sich doch umgebracht. Stimmt, wegen dem Kinderbuch, weil das so schlecht ankam. Ich meine, wir können ja mal eine Kurzgeschichte Hysterien und Schmier für Rienchen schreiben und dann vielleicht, falls Hörer Kinder haben, können die dann das den Kindern vorlesen und dann deren Reaktionen aufnehmen, was die dazu sagen. Weil dann brauchen wir Feedback. So der Hobbit, da war ja auch der, ich glaube der Neffe oder so von Tolkien, hat den Hobbit gelesen und hat gesagt, ja, ist ein gutes Buch und dann wurde es veröffentlicht. Oder so, oder halt irgendwie eine Generation drunter, hat das Buch gelesen und hat so eine Bewertung geschrieben, so eine einseitige Bewertung. So, ja, ist gut für Kinder zwischen acht und zwölf. Aber eigentlich so eine, naja, ich habe das nicht zu Ende gelesen, aber Opa will hören, wie es geht. Niemand hat den Horbitt zu Ende gelesen, niemand, als diese Steinriesen anfangen da, da sagst du, das ist ein bisschen weit gegriffen, mein Lieber, die Riesenspinne habe ich noch gekauft, aber jetzt Steinmonster, weiss ich nicht, weiss ich nicht, weiss ich nicht. Nachtrag, du hast ja vor zwei Folgen, letzte Woche ganz vergessen, hast du eine Kurzgeschichte zum Besten gegeben durch mich, ich habe die vorgelesen, ich habe die einlesen dürfen. Du wolltest unbedingt meine Geschichte einlesen. Und hat es dir das Freude gebracht? Ja, ich habe ewig gebraucht dafür. Wirklich? Auch weil ich bestimmt achtmal vergessen habe, auf Aufnehmen zu drücken. Dann habe ich es geschafft. Und es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, einzulesen. War aber nicht so einfach, weil... Die Sätze lang waren. Die Sätze lang waren. Ja, das habe ich auch gemerkt. Und durcheinander und teilweise ... Also die haben den Inhalt nicht so transportiert, wie ich mir das gerne gewünscht hätte. Okay. Aber, kleine Kritik, aber was eine coole Prämisse. Ja, ich habe die geschrieben ... Was eine fantastische Prämisse zu sagen, da ist einfach eine Raumfähre auf der Flucht und da hat sich so eine Gelassenheit breit gemacht, weil die einfach jederzeit sterben könnten. Alle sind sich komplett darüber einig. Und wie würden die denn funktionieren? Würden die überhaupt noch was hinbekommen? Es hat mich sehr frustriert, weil ich habe diese Geschichte geschrieben, als ich jung war. Ja, Geschichte. Ja genau, das war es nämlich, weil ich weiß, dass sie noch weitergeht. Wie weiter? Ich habe die aber nicht mehr gefunden. Ich bin so ein Festplatten-Messi, ich kaufe mir einmal mehr eine Festplatte und verwende dann einfach eine neue Festplatte.
Und alles, was auf der alten ist, bleibt da drauf. Und ich habe keine Ordnung, kein System. Und ich habe einfach nur eine neue Festplatte. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich von den letzten alle durchgeguckt und auch auf meinem alten Rechner Backups durchgeguckt, weil ich weiß, dass die Geschichte noch weitergeht. Es gibt nämlich, weil die Hauptfigur wurde ja noch gar nicht eingeführt, wie ihr vielleicht bemerkt habt. Ja, weil die Hauptfigur ist dann nämlich ein Schüler und der irgendwie so einen Preis gewinnt, dass er jetzt die Koordinaten festlegen darf für diesen Hilferuf. Ist jetzt inhaltlich auch egal. Aber ich weiß noch, dass es dann die Szene gab, Schulzimmer, Klassenzimmer und dann kommt diese Lotteriebox rein und die ziehen das los. Und ich weiß es ganz genau, dass ich das geschrieben habe, aber ich habe es nicht mehr gefunden. Ich habe wirklich stundenlang alte Dokumente durchforstet, alte Sachen nicht mehr gefunden. Es geht weiter, aber es geht auch einfach nach dem zweiten Absatz dieser Geschichte, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist wirklich, nee, es ist der zweite Absatz. Der erste Absatz hört mitten im Satz auf, der zweite natürlich auch. Also da ist es überhaupt kein System. Aber mich hat es nur geärgert, dass ich nicht zumindest alle Brocken, die ich geschrieben habe, finde. Aber irgendwo ist das noch. Vielleicht wird das irgendwann nachgetragen. Ich glaube es nicht. Das ist nämlich, wenn Leute sagen, ich hätte damals mal diese Geschichte geschrieben als Kind. Nie ist es eine Geschichte. Ihr habt angefangen, den Absatz einer Geschichte zu schreiben. Aber alle sagen dann immer, generell bei allem, was Menschen sagen, 50, 60 Prozent Bullshit abziehen. Wirklich, weil Leute sagen dann immer, ach, ich habe als Kind immer diese Geschichte geschrieben.
Nein, ich habe als Kind mal bei dieser Sendung mitgemacht.
Nein, ich habe als Kind einen Baum ausgebaut.
Du hast zwei Bretter in den Baum geworfen.
Stimmt, ich habe auch mal versucht, einen Baum auszubauen.
Nein, hast du nicht.
Du wolltest es.
Ja.
Man wollte so vieles. Willen ist nicht machen.
Als Kind habe ich mir mal ein Brettspiel erfunden. Nein, du hast Cluedo nachgebaut.
Habe ich wirklich. Und seitdem habe ich das auch schon erzählt. Bestimmt habe ich dir auch schon mal erzählt, dass ich ein Brettspiel habe. Stimmt nicht. So.
Ich habe eine Soße entwickelt. Was heißt entwickelt? Ich habe zehn bestehende Soßen zusammengemischt.
Ja, das war es. Richtig. Von allem, allem, was Menschen erzählen. Ich spreche Spanisch. Nein, no, no, gracias, no, senores, nada, solo hablo un poco de espanol. Aber ich weiß noch, dass ich es mir damals, weil ich war Star Wars Fan und ich habe es mir zur Aufgabe gemacht, alle Star Wars Filme... Bist du wirklich Star Wars? Ach so, das war noch nicht... Ja. Ich habe mir extra ein schwarzes Heft gekauft und habe gesagt, da schreibe ich jetzt die Geschichte von, die gesamte Geschichte von Star Wars rein. Und weil Episode 1 da gerade rauskam, dachte ich, jetzt kann ich endlich anfangen mit Episode 1, weil ich kann ja nicht mit Episode 4 anfangen, ich muss mit Episode 1 anfangen. Aber dann muss man den ganzen Döscher-Bings-Quatsch aufschreiben, dann hat man auch schon keine Lust mehr. Und dann ich eine Zusammenfassung von Episode 1 geschrieben und wollte dann eine Zusammenfassung von allen neun. Und ich wusste damals schon, dass es neun sind. Ich habe damals in die Einleitung geschrieben, dieses Buch wird erst fertig sein, wenn alle neun Teile draußen sind. Ich weiß nicht, warum, wie das damals, ob das immer schon so ein Ding war, es gibt neun Teile, ob das Lucas irgendwann mal gesagt hat, vielleicht schon. Aber auf jeden Fall wusste ich damals schon, es wird neun Teile geben und dann habe ich den ersten Teil zusammengefasst und auch da merkt man, die erste Seite sind die ersten zwei Szenen zusammengefasst, bis ich irgendwann merke, wenn ich so weitermache, dauert das ewig und dann so, ja dann kämpfen die da und dann finden sie Anakin und dann gewinnen sie und ciao. Ja, auch sehr enttäuscht. Der erste aber auch schwierige Teil, weil du dich erst mal durch die Steuerrechte der Handelsföderation durcharbeiten musst musst. Ja, da sagst du mit einem halben Juraabschluss um da Handelsföderationsgesetz. Genau, ich glaube, du musst da wirklich mindestens einen Juraabschluss, um das überhaupt aufschreiben zu können. Welche Vertragsstrafen da jetzt Nabu drohen, wenn sie welche Handelsabkommen... Wenn die Blockade jetzt ignorieren würden. Naja, jedenfalls... It's a Kids-Movie. It's a Kids-Movie. It's a Fairy-Tale. Ja, ja, hier habt ihr St Jada Binks. Leute, die es so ernst nehmen, machen es falsch. Es ist einfach im Kern ein Film über Handelsverträge. Im Prinzip ist Jada Binks Schnieferinchen. Auf eine lustige Art lenkt er dich ab von den eigentlichen Problemen, die es auf der Welt gibt. Ja, es stimmt schon. Aber du könntest ja diese Geschichte machen über kleinen Hitler, der aber kurz bevor er Reichskanzler wird, dann krank wird. Ein Laserschwert. Ne, krank wird. Weil Hysterischen, die Verinchen sagen, oh, der ist gefährlich, der muss aufgehalten werden, machen ihn krank und dann wird halt irgendwie Tesla oder so Reichskanzler oder eine andere coole Figur und der macht dann halt alles. Er macht dann so Raumschiffe und Space und alles ist cool und Hitler liegt krank im Bett, während alle anderen Spaß haben. So gesehen ein bisschen unfair, aber wenn man weiß. Unfair, weil Hitler im Bett liegt. Ja, weil er noch nicht das gemacht hat, was Hitler gemacht hat. Dann müssen die Eltern erklären, was er gemacht hätte, wenn er nicht krank im Bett liegen wäre. Ich kenne ihn nicht ganz voll. Reichskanzler Tesla, wie er gerade so das rote Band durchschneidet von so einem grossen Info.
Bestimmt, ohne Scheiss machen wir sich vor, vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, wenn du halt alle Macht hast, machst du halt auch Scheiße. Aber dann ist es halt Reichskanzler Tesla. Ja. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie du auf den kommst, weil er in der Politik gar nicht ist, zeitlich und politisch ganz weit entfernt. Ja, aber er ist eine relativ positiv gesehene historische Figur. Ach so. Und er schneidet gerade das rote Band vor seinem grossen UFO durch und alle jubeln ihm zu.
Und man sieht so, im Hintergrund ist so ein Fenster, wo Hitler mit so einem Fiebertherometer und so einem Schal am Fenster steht und sagt, schade, warum bin ich nicht dabei.
Schade.
Und dann kannst du sagen, dann steigen die in den Himmel und dann hast du den Catchphrase, schnief, schnief, schnief, hust, hust, ein neuer Tag geht zu Ende, du jetzt schlafen musst, Ende, Ende. So, und dann ist die Geschichte zu Ende und das Kind freut sich und schläft ein und ist gesund.
Aber stell dir mal vor, Tesla wäre da viel gefährlichere Hitler gewesen vielleicht. Weil wenn den plötzlich so einen Grössenwagen gepackt hätte, der hätte auch noch richtig was in der Birne. So richtig was in der Birne. Ja gut, aber Elektrizität ist ja begrenzt. Weil der hätte dann so Elektroarmeen gebaut. So Elektroschockern. Wir hätten alle, das ist ja wirklich dann wie das Imperium geworden, alle hätten so krasse Blaster gehabt und sowas. Das wäre gut gewesen. Aber auch als Kind habe ich bestimmt fünf Tagebücher angefangen, die findet man bei mir noch zu Hause und dann denkt man immer, ach geil, die Tagebücher und es sind fünf Notizbücher, wo ich die erste Seite geschrieben habe und dann schon die Schrift auch immer grösser und lascher wurde. Der Füller geht aus. Füller geht aus und dann irgendwie noch so ein Blutfleck und so, weil dann plötzlich irgendwie Nasen, keine Ahnung, Nasenbluten oder sowas, dann leer. Blüterinchen, Blutkowski, Rolf Blutkowski. Ah, Blutkowski, Herr Blutkowski. Ist nicht so schlimm, ist ein bisschen Blut. Du hast genug Kostnäulich, der Blut ist passt schon. Herr Blutkowski, hallo. Wie geht's Ihnen? Bin bald wieder weg. Ein bisschen Eis in den Nacken, dann bin ich wieder weg. Wie so wieder... Müssen wir denn... Also, weil das sagt man ja häufig, entweder nach hinten, den Kopf in den Nacken. Soll man das machen oder soll man das nicht mehr machen, Herr Blutkowski? Na, ich sag mal, bei einem kleinen Wodka, Kopf in den Nacken, immer gerne. Kopf in den Nacken, immer gerne, gleich wieder weg. Herr Blutkowski ist gleich wieder weg. Ich bin nur kurz da, ich wollte nur kurz gucken, bin gleich wieder weg. Ich bin nur ein bisschen gucken. Herr Blutkowski bleibt nie lang. Nee, der ist nur für ein paar Seiten.
Irgendwie süss.
Ich habe auch Tagebuch geführt und ich habe teilweise, ich habe dann immer das Datum auch geschrieben. Und teilweise habe ich halt wirklich Zeitsprünge von sechs Jahren oder so drin, wo man einfach merkt so, weißt du, 14.04.1998, 16.04.1998, 2011. Einfach so ein Riesensprung, wo man einfach merkt, du bist nicht der Gewissenhaftste.
Und man hat sich auch ein bisschen entfremdet von seinem Tagebuch und muss wieder so anfangen. Ja, was passiert? Ich war siebzehn Mal unglücklich verliebt, habe einen besten Freund verloren, bin mit dem Fahrrad hingefallen und habe im Schultheater gespielt. So, weiter geht's, die neue Staffel Simpsons. Ja, mega, oder? Geil, wie damals. Und dann fängt man genau in welchem Ton an, über Bart Simpson zu sprechen.
Ja. Ja, na ja. Ich weiß noch, in einem Etaubuchantrag habe ich geschrieben, ich habe mir 100 Sticker bestellt. Und diese Sticker sind nie angekommen. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich diese Sticker jemals bekommen habe. Aber ich habe zumindest Beweis, dass ich sie bestellt habe. Oh, vielleicht ist es vor Gericht sogar noch gültig. Kann schon sein, weil es gab so von so einem Heft, das ich hatte, gab so ein Gewinnspiel, dass man Aufkleber bestellen musste. Und die klebt man dann irgendwo hin, macht ein Foto davon, schickt das ein und dann kann man was gewinnen. Und ich habe damals in meinem Tagebuch geschrieben, Propaganda-Sticker. Ich habe damals in meinem Tagebuch geschrieben, ich habe 100 Sticker bestellt. Aber ich habe gar nicht vor, an dem Gewinnspiel teilzunehmen. Ich will einfach nur die Sticker für mich haben. Das habe ich nur im Tagebuch anvertraut, das wusste so niemand, dass ich Stickerbetrug, eine der schwersten Betrugsform, machen kann. Ja, aber durch so ein altes Rechtsurteil immer noch tatsächlich mit der Tolstrafe. Ja, tatsächlich, das klebt Jahre später noch an dir. Das klebt wortwörtlich Jahre später. Das kriegst du nicht aus den Haaren, egal wie oft du die wäscht, kriegst du einfach nicht raus. Das funktioniert nicht. Ja, es passiert viel. Es passiert einiges, wundert euch nicht, falls ihr demnächst in Bahnhofs Kiosk geht und dort einen grossen Aufbau von Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen seht, vielleicht der neue Stern am Himmel, vielleicht das neue Harry Potter, wer weiss, vielleicht kriegen wir Emma Watson nochmal dazu für die Verfilmung oder sowas. Guck, wenn das das neue Harry Potter wird, ey. Meinst du, das kann nur sein. Ja, so viel Arbeit. Ja, das ist was, oder? Was ist das für ein Druck drauf ist? Also das erste Buch schreibst du ja irgendwie aus Spaß. Du hast dich in die Idee verliebt, auch wie geil. Dann gibt es da irgendwie geil so ein, dann lernen die da zaubern.
Dann hast du vier Häuser und dann gibt es so Bandenkriege und so Klassen, School Pride.
Und dann finden das Leute geil und du musst dir das Ganze nochmal ausdenken.
Ja, nervig.
Und dann noch achtmal.
Leute, das ist doch bescheuert.
Deswegen, eigentlich muss man hoffen, dass es nicht erfolgreich wird, diese ganzen Sachen.
Ich hoffe nur, dass es das nicht schon gibt. Österreich-Schnieferinchen. Was ist das, was man gegoogelt? Google mal. Von unten hat sich sein Nokia 6230 herausgeholt und tippt jetzt. Guck mal, wann hast du das letzte Mal dieses Suchergebnis gesehen? Wow, wenn man Schnieferinchen eingibt, gibt es keinen Sucheintrag. Keinen einzigen Eintrag bei Google. Es wurden keine mit einer Suchanfrage Schnieferinchen übereinstimmenden Dokumente gefunden. Dokumente? Ja. Vorschläge, achte darauf, dass alle Wörter richtig geschrieben sind, sehen Sie, probiere es mit anderen Suchbegriffen, können wir machen, probiere es mit allgemeineren Suchbegriffen. Was müssen wir jetzt machen? Kinderbuch wir das irgendwie schützen lassen, diesen Begriff? Nee, ich glaube, das reicht, wenn das im Podcast hier mit Datum versehen fällt. Heute ist der 26. Mai 2020 und hiermit gehört uns marken- und bildrechtlich Schnieferinchen. Und Hysterich. Ja. Wieso nicht? Ich will gerne über den Namen sprechen. Was hast du gegen Hüsterich? Wieso Rüchrich ist keine Änderung von... Naja, das ist halt so... Naja, wie würdest du ihn nennen? Hüsti, Hüstel. Hüstel. Hüstel und Schnieferienchen. Na, Hüstel, da geht es doch ein bisschen ins Österreichische. Ja, Hüstel und Schnieferieferlinchen. Deutschland ist ja der größere Markt, du willst ja nicht Österreich jetzt als Zielgruppe. Kein Geld. Aber Hüsterich wegen Erich, oder was? Du, du wirst sehen, du wirst schon sehen, wie ich am Kinderbuchhimmel aufsteige. Das ist eine geniale Idee. Das ist wirklich genial. Das ist krank und die Eltern haben, ah, jetzt endlich können wir was vorlesen. Da musst du halt nur so lange warten, bis das Kind krank ist. Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Vielleicht müssen wir ein bisschen nachhelfen. Ah, ja, ja, wieder die Grundwasser-Idee? Mhm. Oh, ich habe jetzt wahrscheinlich Legionellen bei mir in der Wohnung. Boah, das klingt cool. Klingt cool, ne? Legionell. Vielleicht soll ich nichts dagegen tun. Ist das so ein Asterix- und Obelix-Problem oder was? Die Legionellen! Die Legionellen! Oh mein Gott, das ist total geil, wenn wir das in den Bayer Hüsterich und Stieferinchen, wenn dann kurz Legionellen zu Tausenden vor den Toren stehen. Legionellen mit so Katapulten auch. Aber was ist das? Sind das Kreaturen, Kinder? Das sind kleine, furchterregende, Salmonellen-artige Dinge, die sich von innen aus töten, weil ich Stagnation, Standwasser bei mir vielleicht habe. Naja, ich halte euch auf dem Laufenden, vor allem durch mein Am-Leben-Bleiben halte ich euch auf dem Laufenden. Ja, wir hoffen. Weil es tödlich. Wir hoffen's.
Wir hoffen's, ansonsten sehen wir uns
nicht mehr wieder. Es hat mir fast Spaß gemacht.
Es war eine fantastische Zeit mit euch.
216 Folgen, glaube ich, ist ein guter Punkt, wo man sagt,
passt, du hast alles gesagt.
Ja. Falls nicht, geht's nächste
Woche weiter. Wir freuen uns, wir bleiben gespannt.
Alle guten Dinge sind nämlich 217.
Allerdings. Ich freue mich sehr, sehr auf die nächste Folge.
Hauterin, wie wir gesagt haben, wie wir nie gesagt haben.
Macht es gut, haut rein.
Macht es gut, hauterin.
Ich würde sagen, wir heben ab.
Wir heben ab.
Heben ab.
Ciao.
It's a voice-by-production.